pourvu que ça dure vous est présenté par
écho DDS éco-organismes qui agit pour
une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
co-responsables sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui focus sur le transport
aérien actuellement il pèse entre deux
trois pour cent des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais cette pollution va
s'aggraver avec l'explosion du trafic
dans les prochaines années tous les
acteurs de la filière sont engagés pour
tenter de décarboner l'aviation
renouvellement de la flotte
électrification biocarburant ou encore
avion hydrogène les pistes manquent pas
mais sont-elles réalisables réponse dans
cette émission parmi ces briques
technologiques pour rendre l'avion plus
vert il y a bien sûr la motorisation
alors à quoi ressemblera le moteur de
l'avion du futur entretient avec Olivier
Andries le patron de safran enfin cette
révolution verte ne se fera évidemment
pas sans Airbus l'avionneur qui est sur
tous les fronts reportage à Toulouse au
siège du groupe mais d'abord tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur l'empreinte
carbone du secteur aérien en moins d'une
minute c'est parti
l'avion un mode de transport très
polluant et oui il rejette du CO2 via la
combustion du kérosène dans ses
réacteurs résultat le transport aérien
génère près d'un milliard de tonnes de
deux parents soit 2 à 3% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
c'est peu quand on sait que le transport
dans sa globalité est responsable de 25%
des émissions de CO2 mais si on regarde
les émissions par voyageur et par qui le
maître là l'avion émet jusqu'à 280 g de
CO2 contre 150 g pour une voiture 72 g
pour 1 2 roues 68 g pour un bus et 14 g
pour un train il n'y a pas que le CO2
qui pollue l'atmosphère et oui l'avion
émet également de l'oxyde d'azote des
particules fines mais aussi des traînés
de condensation qui sont aussi
redoutables que le CO2 et dans les
années à venir ça va empirer et oui le
trafic devrait être multiplié par deux
ou trois d'ici 2050 avec 10 milliards de
passagers du coup si rien n'est fait
21,2 milliards de tonnes de CO2 pourrait
être rejeté dans l'atmosphère d'ici 30
ans en 2021 la TAG lears transport
action Group qui réunit tous les acteurs
du secteur c'est fixé un nouvel objectif
atteindre la neutralité carbone d'ici
[Musique]
face à l'urgence climatique le transport
aérien n'a pas d'autre choix que de se
verdir Jérôme Bouchard bonjour bonjour
associer chez Oliver weimon et expert en
aéronautique alors on va le voir à tous
les acteurs du secteur sont sur le pont
le secteur qui dispose en fait de toute
une palette de briques de briques
technologiques qu'il faut assembler un
petit peu comme dans un puzzle on va les
passer en revue ensemble sachant que
elles ont toutes une temporalité un
petit peu différente certaines briques
existent déjà et d'autres seront
effectives dans un horizon un peu plus
lointain déjà le renouvellement des
flottes d'avion c'est vraiment un levier
de décarbonation sur lequel on peut agir
maintenant tout de suite c'est quelque
chose qui nous est disponible maintenant
en quelques données les avions en 20 ans
ont amélioré leur performances en termes
d'émission de 20%. et ce chiffre est
tout à fait extensible des avions il y a
50 ans et mettez à peu près 50% de
carbone mais c'est suffisant pour que le
secteur soit neutre en émission carbone
la raison 2050 de miséricordieux
c'est quand même une petite partie
d'équation qui je le rappelle est
immédiatement accessible donc
aujourd'hui un avion a une durée de vie
d'à peu près 25 ans donc les avions qui
sont mis en service en 2020 finiront
leur vie en 2047 donc on va se dire que
l'aviation est un secteur à cycle long
donc les progrès qui sont faits sont
faits mais par contre la flotte ne va
pas se verdir immédiatement elle
continuera à progresser lentement mais
la croissance du trafic passager fera
que malheureusement on restera toujours
dans un surplus d'émission alors il y a
un autre levier effectivement tout de
suite à la marge ou pas je vous pose la
question mais on peut jouer sur la
trajectoire je savais pas la trajectoire
de vol de manière optimisée en gros
l'avion l'idée c'est qu'il soit ultra
connecté qui communique entre les avions
et donc et leur environnement et donc
ils consomment moins carburant c'est ça
l'idée c'est exactement ça alors ça pour
la peine c'est un vrai levier
supplémentaire ça peut apporter 3 à 4%
de réduction de l'émission par vol alors
on n'est pas encore au verdissement
total mais c'est le premier pas le fait
d'optimiser les trajectoires et
particulièrement indécente vers les
aéroports en utilisant la gravité va
permettre de réduire la consommation et
donc les émissions bon il faut après des
carburants aussi qui soit moins
polluants c'est là que les biocarburant
vont entrer en jeu c'est la solution qui
apparaît aujourd'hui comme la plus
pragmatique la plus simple à court terme
d'ailleurs les compagnies commencent à
les utiliser mais encore une fois la
marge très progressivement aujourd'hui
on a 1% 2% de leur réservoir qui remplit
sur ce qu'on appelle le socialable
aviation fioul il y a beaucoup de
biocarburant c'est vrai mais je pense
que ça ne sera pas la meilleure solution
parce que les biocarburants ça demande
des terres arables ça demande aussi pas
mal d'eau donc ça déplace un peu le
problème donc c'est pas une solution les
bicarburants c'est une première solution
mais moi je crois plus tôt à une sorte
de circularité c'est à dire que on a des
projets aujourd'hui dans l'industrie
aéronautique où on va récupérer le
carbone de l'air dans des grosses
machines qui ressemblent à des séchoirs
à cheveux géants et où ce carbone après
on va le recombiner pour en faire du
carburant qui sera réinjecté dans les
avions donc ça c'est pour moi cette
circularité carbone elle est beaucoup
plus intéressante elle est un peu plus
loin technologiquement parlant mais à
horizon 2030 par exemple mais elle a au
moins le mérite de ne pas rajouter
d'empreinte carbone à ce qui est déjà je
suis allé dire consommer en même temps
la France a des engagements qui sont
forts sur ces biocarburants on va
pouvoir remplir ces objectifs là
la vraie question aujourd'hui à court
terme c'est les subventions qui sont
liées au biocarburant on a bien vu
qu'aux États-Unis récemment le fait de
donner un dollar par galon a fait
développer considérablement l'histoire
des biocarburants maintenant est-ce que
on arrivera à faire la même chose en
France je le souhaite et je l'espère
est-ce que ça sera vraiment durable
c'est une autre question en même temps
dans les deux cas ça coûte cher
bioparbure en carburant de santé c'est
très cher et là on se dit que les prix
des billets d'avion vont devoir
forcément augmenter signe c'est une
quasi certitude ça alors déjà ça coûte
plus cher oui on va dire que du
carburant de synthèse ou du biocarburant
c'est 4 fois plus cher que le kérosène
et on sait que le prix
dans un billet d'avion c'est 30%. donc
déjà si on ne fait juste un petit calcul
mathématiques ça tient pas boum ça tient
pas mais ça tient pas du tout donc c'est
pour ça que je vous disais il faut
peut-être penser à des subventions il y
a d'autres aides premier point deuxième
point est-ce qu'on va avoir une
augmentation du coût des billets d'avion
bon moi j'ai pas de boule de cristal
mais on sent bien que c'est une tendance
de fond
lié au carburant ou lié à une éventuelle
taxe carbone qui pourrait être mise en
place à terme il va falloir que le
passager dans une certaine mesure
contribue à la réduction des émissions
maintenant j'espère parce que je suis
passager moi aussi qu'on va réussir à
maintenir cette augmentation dans une
mesure acceptable bon après on peut
rêver voler dans des agents des
batteries ou des piles à combustible le
problème c'est qu'elles sont lourdes ces
batteries et pas assez puissantes donc
la solution ce sont peut-être des
moteurs hybrides à la fois électrique et
thermique oui moi je crois quand même à
une horizon 10 à 15 ans à l'hybridation
donc on sera pas forcément sur des
avions de type 3 vins voilà qu'on
utilise pour faire Paris Toulouse et
encore moins sur des avions qui nous
permettent de traverser les océans mais
quand on regarde des avions régionaux
pour des trajets de 3-400 km on pourra
avoir des avions hybrides qui
contiennent moins de passagers peut-être
19 passagers comme l'avion Héra Dora
héros qui a un exemple et qui nous
permettront de voyager là pour la peine
avec une émission considérablement
réduite par rapport aux technologies
actuelles donc l'hybridation plus que
tout électrique dans un premier temps
oui l'hybridation plus que le tout
électrique c'est sûr il faudra en passer
par cette brique là il reste après
évidemment ce qui nous fait rêver
d'hydrogène les avions plus gros de plus
longue distance et le pari de
l'hydrogène mais il y a beaucoup
d'obstacles certains disent qu'on n'y
arrivera pas alors moi je suis pas de
cet avis moi je suis un éternel
optimiste l'aviation a toujours vécu de
ces challenge c'est un métier de
pionnier donc il y a 100 ans on pensait
pas qu'on traverserait les océans avec
des 380 qui pèsent 500 tonnes en amenant
500 passagers en moins de 7 heures donc
moi je suis sûr que l'aviation va se
réinventer elle va se décarboner
l'hydrogène est un bon levier pour aller
dans cette direction maintenant c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué parce qu'il
faut réinventer l'avion les avions
n'auront pas la même forme les
réservoirs prendront plus de place
l'hydrogène a une densité énergétique 4
fois moins de recalquée kérosène ça va
changer beaucoup de choses dans la façon
dont les avions sont construits Airbus
là-dessus j'imagine du travail sur toute
la solution elle travaille sur toutes
ces solutions ils ont des équipes
dédiées à la partie hydrogène long terme
mais ils ont bien compris la temporalité
des briques donc ils ont des petites
équipes sur chacun des sujets allez
merci Jérôme Bouchard merci à vous
associez donc chez Oliver whyman expert
en aéronautique merci justement
puisqu'on parle d'Airbus on va avoir
comment l'avionneur est plus que jamais
engagé dans cette quête de l'avion
décarbonée reportage à Toulouse sur le
site d'Airbus signé manuel lagre
en 2022 l'Union européenne annonce au
sommet de l'aviation de Toulouse vouloir
la neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 le défi
est immense on parle dans le secteur
aérien de 1550 milliards de dollars
d'investissement pour les 30 prochaines
années
pour y parvenir Airbus explore plusieurs
pistes en 2022 l'entreprise réalise une
prouesse technique faire voler un Airbus
A380 avec un moteur alimenté par 100% de
carburant durable constitué
principalement d'huile de cuisson usagés
mais vous allez voir Airbus s'est lancé
un défi encore plus fou cet avion va
être celui qui va être utilisé comme
laboratoire volant pour tester les
technologies hydrogène qui sont
développées par Airbus l'hydrogène est
quand même un carburant très prometteur
parce que c'est l'un des seuls ou le
seul qui permet d'avoir zéro émission de
CO2 à la sortie à la sortie du moteur de
l'avion cet avion qui va servir de
cobaye pour les tests ne va pas
totalement être modifié il va conserver
ses quatre réacteurs traditionnels donc
le cinquième moteur sera installé
au-dessus de l'avion donc sur une surex
croissance qui ressemblera une petite
voilure à une petite aile qui sera en
gros entre la dérive et la porte que
vous voyez là bas et donc sur un texte
croissance qu'on appelle un stop on sera
capable d'installer plusieurs types de
moteur à hydrogène l'objectif est de
comparer le comportement des réacteurs
traditionnels avec celui à l'hydrogène
ce qui inquiète les ingénieurs ce ne
sont pas les moteurs mais les réservoirs
d'hydrogène à l'intérieur du fuselage
donc là on est à l'arrière de l'avion
vraiment près de la de la queue de
l'avion on se trouve sur le pont
principal et dans cette zone là on va
stocker l'hydrogène qui va être utilisé
pour les essais donc l'hydrogène va être
stockée sous forme liquide c'est-à-dire
à moins 253 degrés donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle de l'hydrogène cryogénique il
faut savoir que sous cette forme là
l'hydrogène va contenir trois fois plus
d'énergie que ce qu'on pourrait avoir
dans un dans du carburant classique dans
du kérosène mais va être en contrepartie
4 fois plus volumineux donc le défi du
stockage de l'hydrogène et quelque chose
de clé et sur lequel on va travailler
sur ce projet là air c'est fixé pour
objectif de réaliser les premiers vols
fin 2026 si les tests sont concluants un
premier avion hydrogène pourrait voir le
jour en 2035
mais l'énergie et l'amélioration des
moteurs ne sont pas les seules pistes
explorées par Airbus pour voyager plus
écolo
chez OPEX la filiale d'Airbus chargée
d'accélérer le développement des
technologies futures on s'intéresse aux
ailes qui équiperont les avions de
demain
[Musique]
est liée à la performance de l'avion et
la performance de l'avion est donnée par
les designs des tonnelles et qui soit
capable de réduire les émissions et la
consommation des carburants des 5 à 10%.
voici la maquette de l'aile du futur en
taille réelle elle mesure à 5 mètres de
plus que celle qui équipe actuellement
nos avions et ressemblera aux ailes des
albatros
qui sont un peu comme des plumes sous
les oiseaux qui vont modifier la forme
arrodynamique de la de l'aile pendant
toutes les phases du vol une aile ultra
performante qui s'adaptera aux
conditions météo et qui fera mieux face
au vent pour optimiser sa consommation
de carburant des solutions il en existe
pour les avions de ligne et gros
porteurs mais qu'en est-il pour
l'aviation légère considéré comme
polluantes bruyante ou réservée à une
élite l'aviation de loisirs en France
ses 51 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en 2020 dont 33 milliards à
l'export au niveau de la finition on va
pas avoir besoin de charger le carbone
de trop donc
super
nous avons rendez-vous à Toulouse chez
aura Aero ici la transition écologique
est en marche on utilise aujourd'hui un
moteur thermique un moteur à combustion
qui est un moteur qu'on achète sur le
marché qui existe depuis de nombreuses
années demain c'est-à-dire avant la fin
de l'année 2023 on va remplacer tout ce
moteur thermique par un moteur
électrique qui est de plus faible
dimension et sur lequel on a un volume
très important pour accueillir des
batteries ça sera la première fois que
notamment un avion de formation capable
voltige
volera avec une solution 100% batterie
aura un héros ne compte pas s'arrêter à
l'avion électrique biplace il a pour
objectif la mise en service d'un avion
de transport inter régional hybride de
19 places d'ici 2027
[Musique]
on l'a vu les innovations ne manquent
pas pour des carboner l'avion autre
levier pour accompagner cette révolution
verte des moteurs moins gourmands et
plus efficaces bonjour les viandries
bonjour David merci d'être là avec nous
directeur général du motoriste safran
motoriste équipe entière aéronautique
voilà pour être précis est-ce qu'on
éclaire sur le fait que le moteur à
combustion va rester pendant encore
plusieurs années voire plusieurs
décennies la seule technologie capable
de faire voler un avion plusieurs
décennies j'en suis absolument convaincu
et avec le moteur à combustion on fait
de la décarbonation en fait sans le
savoir depuis des dizaines d'années
puisqu'on est sur un schéma ou
l'industrie aéronautique mondiale dans
le domaine des moteurs à réduit la
consommation de carburant d'environ 1%
par an chaque année depuis plus de 30
ans donc l'idée c'est d'améliorer
l'efficacité énergétique et donc
effectivement des moteurs notamment
effectivement la décarbonation de
l'aviation
par la sobriété et la sobriété ça passe
notamment par la technologie et le
développement de moteurs qui sont
toujours plus performants en termes de
réduction de consommation de carburant
et donc de réduction d'émissions de gaz
carbonique puisque c'est
ça va mais comment on améliore tout ça
il faut des moteurs plus gros il faut il
faut quoi alors c'est de la technologie
effectivement c'est des nouvelles
générations de moteur et donc pour cela
sans rentrer dans trop de détails
techniques il faut améliorer ce qu'on
appelle l'efficacité propulsive du
moteur et l'efficacité thermique du
moteur et donc comment est-ce qu'on y
arrive sur l'efficacité propulsive ça
passe notamment par une augmentation de
la taille de ce qu'on appelle la
soufflante la soufflante c'est la partie
avant du moteur d'avion c'est le convoi
quand on embarque dans un avion c'est le
moulin en quelque sorte et au plus la
taille de cette soufflante est grande au
plus on brasse de l'air en quelque sorte
on brasse de l'air on crée de la poussée
sans de l'air qui ne passe pas par la
chambre de combustion et ça ça permet
d'améliorer l'efficacité propulsive de
l'avion donc les générations de moteur
suivantes auront des diamètres de
soufflant de fans en anglais qui seront
de plus en plus importants ça c'est
l'efficacité propulsive et l'efficacité
thermique ça passe par tout le travail
sur les nouveaux matériaux qui tiennent
des températures plus élevées au centre
de ce qu'on appelle la chambre de
combustion on assiste à un
renouvellement de la flotte des
compagnies aériennes avec des avions
plus performants et des moteurs plus
performants qui sont équipés de votre
moteur notamment le moteur lip qui
équipe la 320 Neo et là le Boeing 737
MAX en quoi est-ce que encore une fois
c'est plus performant aujourd'hui qu'il
y a qu'il y a quelques années il y a une
dizaine d'années on a décidé de lancer
une nouvelle génération de moteur qui
s'appelle le lip le lip qui motorise à
la fois le les dernières générations de
Boeing et d'Airbus donc le 737 MAX et la
320 néo et qui apporte 15% de économie
de carburant par rapport à la génération
précédente et donc tous les avions qui
sont introduits sur le marché
aujourd'hui qui sont actuellement
produits et livrés par Airbus et par
Boeing sont des avions avec ces derniers
technologies de moteur qui apporte 15 %
de réduction de démission de gaz
carbonique et donc de consommation de
carburant par rapport aux génération
presse et ces moteurs qui sont capables
d'accueillir les nouveaux carburants
propres les bocarburants ce qu'il faut
attendre la future génération de moteurs
ce qu'on appelle les open rotor alors
les moteurs lip sont certifiés pour
fonctionner jusqu'à 50% avec des
carburants dit durables les carburants
durables aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelle les biocarburants ou des
carburants issus de la biomasse ou de
retraitement de d'huile
usagées en fait ça c'est une limite de
certification donc on est actuellement
avec les avionneurs en train de faire
des essais en vol pour voir si on peut
pousser cette limite vers le haut mais
le panne rotor est-ce que c'est pas ça
l'outil j'ai envie de dire de demain
pour l'avion de demain l'avion hydrogène
l'avion électrique
il y a un saut générationnel vraiment
avec
nous nous sommes engagés collectivement
le monde de l'aéronautique s'est engagé
collectivement au mois d'octobre 2021
à atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 et pour y arriver il y a plusieurs
leviers mais les deux leviers essentiels
sont la technologie au niveau de l'avion
et au niveau du moteur et puis ce qu'on
appelle les carburants durables sur la
technologie nous sommes convaincus
nous sommes convaincus qu'en travaillant
et en mettant sur le marché un avion et
un moteur disruptif on sera capable de
faire des économies de carburant de
l'ordre de 30 à 35% par rapport au toute
dernière génération d'avion qui sont
actuellement produites et sa disruption
elle est pourtant elle est pourtant 2035
c'est pour 2035 donc un saut de 30%.
dont 20% serait apporté par le moteur et
une dizaine de % par la violeur et donc
sur le motoriste les 20% qu'on
apporterait pour cela on est obligé
d'aller vers des architectures de moteur
disruptive en rupture et donc et
notamment nous nous avons décidé de
travailler ce qu'on appelle un moteur
non Carné le moteur non Carné ça nous
permet d'augmenter le diamètre de la
soufflante encore plus
et donc c'est ce qu'on appelle un open
rotor ou un open fan donc ça sera un
moteur qui ressemblera
qui est qui n'est pas Carné donc il est
quelque part on a cassé on a cassé les
murs pour augmenter le diamètre de la
souffrance et le rendre encore plus
performant et donc on est où exactement
aujourd'hui du projet parce que 2035 ça
paraît effectivement assez loin alors
oui mais dans l'aéronautique pour
arriver à une entrée en service en 2035
ça veut dire qu'il faut que les
avionneurs lancent leurs projets d'avion
vers les années 2027 2028 et ils le
feront en faisant le choix de notre
technologie de moteur si nous avons pu
démontrer d'ici là que non seulement
nous apportons la performance mais que
nous apportons également les meilleurs
garanties de sécurité en vol et donc il
y a tout un programme de développement
technologique et décès au sol et en vol
qui doivent être faits pour apporter
cette preuve de performance et de
maturité technologique dont les
avionnaires ont besoin et c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille intensément maintenant
donc le calendrier de 2035 il peut
paraître à nos auditeurs relativement
lointains mais à l'échelle de
l'aéronautique c'est demain après il y a
aussi une question comme c'est un gros
moteur il sera installé oups qui descend
à selle sans carénage il pourra se
placer sous les ailes comme comme pour
les moteurs actuels et ce qu'il faut
revoir le look l'architecture de des
avions alors c'est évidemment aux
aveneurs de travailler sur la meilleure
architecture d'avion possible mais on
peut on peut imaginer a priori trois
options possibles l'option actuelle qui
est des moteurs qui sont sous elles
sous-elle basse et ça ça suppose quand
même d'avoir des jambes assez longues
parce qu'il faudra de la place sous
l'aile pour accommoder le moteur l'autre
solution c'est d'avoir des des ailes
hautes
des ailes hautes et la troisième
solution c'est de les mettre à l'arrière
mais ça ça sera une décision qui sera
prise par l'avionneur qui doit
travailler dans le cas de ces
avant-projets sur l'intérêt de ces
différentes options voilà merci beaucoup
merci pour cette entretien d'encolivier
Andries directeur général de sa
franc-mercie à vous merci David alors on
l'a vu bocarburant sont une des
solutions pour décarboner l'avion mais
ils ont ce terme de ne pas en avoir
assez pour satisfaire toute la demande
pour autant un peu carburant nouvelle
génération vous allez voir s'annonce
prometteur
[Musique]
l'hydrogène les moteurs électriques ce
ne sera pas avant 2050 en attendant si
on veut accélérer dans la décarbonation
les biocarburants sont incontournables
bonjour Émilie bonjour Aujourd'hui on
peut compter essentiellement sur l'huile
de friture mais d'ici quelques années et
ben le stock il sera épuisé et oui alors
vous l'avez dit effectivement
aujourd'hui nous avions y volent avec 1%
de biocarburant en 2025 toute l'Europe
devra passer à 2% puis à 6% en 2030 à
37% à 2041 enfin à 85% en 2050 alors
David je ne sais pas si on sera encore
là pour voir ça en tout cas si on doit
compter que sur l'huile de cuisson
usagée pas sûr que ce soit suffisant en
voyant large on pourra produire aller
jusqu'à un million de tonnes de
biocarburants par an à l'échelle
mondiale ça sera évidemment pas
suffisant si on veut atteindre notre
objectif de 2 millions de tonnes en 2030
pour respecter le seuil des 6%, il fera
donc évidemment trouver des solutions
alternatives et ces solutions ce sont
les biocarburants deuxième génération et
aujourd'hui deux pistes tiennent
l'accordéon alors première piste l'idée
c'est de brûler nos déchets ménagers via
un procédé thermochimique complet qui
s'appelle le procédé de Fisher trop la
deuxième piste c'est la fermentation et
bien on utilise tout simplement du sucre
pour fabriquer du biocarburant et ça
vous dit sans doute quelque chose car
c'est comme ça que l'on fabrique
aujourd'hui à l'éthanol de nos voitures
mais avec cette fermentation on peut
aussi produire une autre molécule très
recherchée dans la pétrochimie qui
s'appelle l'isobuten Emilie c'est du
pétrole c'est vrai à la base des
hôpitaux du pétrole d'ailleurs pour
fabriquer beaucoup de choses avec des
produits cosmétiques du plastique et
même du kérosène mais comme je vous
disais il existe une manière donc
naturelle de le produire via la
fermentation et c'est d'ailleurs ce sur
quoi travaille une société qui s'appelle
la société globale bioénergie alors pour
l'instant il va pas à pas dans des
univers d'ailleurs très différents
d'abord dans la fabrication de produits
cosmétiques elle a commencé l'année
dernière en 2022 et puis bientôt la
fabrication de biocarburant pour la
Formule 1 car rappelons-le tout le
secteur va passer au 100% biocarburant à
horizon 2026
aujourd'hui les biocarburants aériens
c'est vrai mais il doit d'abord lever
des freins des freins administratifs
réglementaires
comme pour tout SAS il faut falloir
passer par les fourches codines d'un
organisme qui s'appelle la STM qui
regroupe en gros tous les acteurs du
secteur ça l'organisme de certification
alors la procédure elle est très longue
elle dure 5 ans et ça a l'air plutôt
bien parti pour global du énergie
globale du énergie qui devrait donc
faire partie de la poignée de
technologie de SAS autorisée donc dans
l'aviation civile bon maintenant que
l'agrément on va dire quasi acté la
société à pouvoir se lancer dans
l'essentiel la production alors pas
avant 208 nous dit la société car il y a
d'autres obstacles à lever alors je vous
le disais cette ISO butane il est
fabriqué à partir de sucre que l'on
produit de deux manières alors d'abord
via des copeaux de bois alors je ne le
savais pas je l'ai appelé en préparant
cette émission le bois il est fait à 66%
à plus de 66% de sucre donc l'idée en
fait c'est de récupérer les déchets des
forêts ou des séries on en a beaucoup
pour pour les transformer en une sorte
de pâte visqueuse qui va d'ailleurs
ressembler à du chocolat et puis la
deuxième matière première qu'on va
pouvoir utiliser pour cette fermentation
c'est la betterave ou plus précisément
la mélasse
[Musique]
de betteraves
mais là si elle est autorisée pour les
voitures mais elle est interdite pour
pour les avions pour l'instant en tout
cas l'Europe interdit soit disant parce
qu'elle entre en concurrence avec la
production alimentaire ce qui est vous
le savez un des écueil des SAS
aujourd'hui et pourtant et pourtant on
va quand même rappeler que la mélasse ce
sont tous les déchets qui ne vont pas
dans notre assiette donc c'est vrai que
cet argument n'est pas très recevable
bon en attendant que l'Europe règle un
petit peu ce problème comment est-ce que
on transforme cette mélasse cette pâte
de bois en vieux carburant c'est très
simple en fait on va leur extraire le
sucre que l'on va mélanger à des
bactéries ça va nous donner donc un de
l'isobutène sous forme gazeuse il ne
reste plus qu'à le purifier légèrement
parce qu'il s'auto purifie tout seul
mais il faut encore le purifier un petit
peu et puis assembler ces molécules
trois par trois pour en faire donc un
liquide le tour est joué votre SAS est
prêt à être utilisé donc un procédé qui
ma foi a l'air assez court il y a peu
d'étapes de transformation exactement ce
procédé il est d'ailleurs plus court que
les procédés concurrents qui d'ailleurs
un net avantage à global bio énergie car
qui dit procéder plus court dit
évidemment procédé moins coûteux et on
va pas se mentir David et SF ils vont
coûter de plus en plus cher à l'avenir
alors pour l'instant c'est vrai que
l'huile de cuisson elle reste
relativement abordable parce que ça
c'est effectivement un produit que l'on
recycle encore que tout est relatif
parce qu'elle coûte quand même déjà deux
à trois fois plus cher que le kérosène
classique mais tous les experts les
experts nous disent à horizon 10 ans les
SF 2e génération vous coûter 4 à 5 fois
plus cher plus cher pardon que le que le
kérosène classique alors global
bioénergie soit en tout cas en produire
à terme 30000 tonnes par an avec un avec
la promesse d'un biocarburant à moins de
5 euros le kilo un biocarburant qui
émettra 3 à 5 fois moins de CO2 que
quelques roses classiques mais aussi
c'est important de le dire zéro traîné
de condensation voilà un nouveau
paradigme merci Émilie voilà c'est la
fin de pourvu que ça dure l'émission qui
rend les correspondables sur Public
Sénat émission à voir ou revoir sur
Public Sénat bien sûr il y a du replay
sur public senna.fr rendez-vous dans
deux semaines
[Musique]
pourvu que ça dure vous a été présenté
par écho DDS éco-organisme qui agit pour
une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]